tras siete horas de deliberaciones y un
juicio de tres meses el Jurado de un
tribunal de Fort Lauderdale en Florida
recomendó que Nicola Cruz autor de la
matanza de parkland se ha condenado a
cadena
perpetuas y de la pena de muerte a pesar
de que la fiscalía la solicitó con
vehemencia
nosotros el Jurado encontramos por
unanimidad que las circunstancias
agravantes son suficientes para
justificar una posible sentencia de
muerte sí uno o más jurados creen que
una o más circunstancias atenuantes han
sido establecidas por el peso de las
pruebas Sí nosotros el Jurado
encontramos por unanimidad que las
circunstancias agravantes que han sido
probadas más allá de la duda superan las
circunstancias atenuantes establecidas
no
el autor del tiroteo no mostró ninguna
reacción al veredicto mientras que los
familiares de las víctimas estaban
devastados
estamos muy decepcionados con el
resultado de hoy debería haber sido la
pena de muerte 100%
17 personas fueron brutalmente
asesinadas el 14 de febrero de 2018
soy más que decepcionada y frustrada por
este resultado no lo entiendo No lo
entiendo
en 2018 Nicolás Cruz mató a 14
estudiantes y tres adultos e hirió a 17
personas en la escuela de la que había
sido expulsado un año antes con un rifle
ar-15 que compró legalmente el tiroteo
desencadenó un movimiento nacional
histórico de protesta contra las armas
pero sin éxito cuatro años después el
país sigue siendo escenario de
mortíferos tiroteos en mayo 19 niños y
dos profesoras fueron asesinados en una
escuela primaria del estado de Texas